look I'm excited about having a
professor Matthew Bon on for a couple
different reasons you know he practices
a professor of the practice of energy
National Security and foreign policy I
mean once again uh give a formal proper
introduction he's an American nuclear
and energy policy analyst currently a
professor practice at the Harvard
Kennedy School at Harvard University
co-principal investigator of the Belfor
Center project on managing the Adam and
his father George Bund was a leading
figure in the field of Arms Control who
helped draft and negotiate the nuclear
non-proliferation Treaty of 1968
limiting the spread of nuclear weapons
worldwide uh Matthew bung it's good to
have you on
if you can hear us
let us know if you can hear us you look
like you're Frozen okay I can hear you
now I can hear you now
can you hear us or no
I can hear you let me know if you'd
rather I turn off my video that might uh
help a little bit you're actually fine
now whatever you're doing now it's fine
so it's it's good to have you on I you
know we got an article that came in and
the team was talking about it where uh
somebody asked you a question how like
these are Russian nuclear strike in
Ukraine and this was on October 2nd 2022
uh an NPR article your answer was we
have a 77 Year tradition some call it a
taboo of a non-use of nuclear weapons
Russia is threatening that
and uh you went on to say a few
different things we need to do
everything we can to maintain that
tradition of not using nuclear weapons
in combat so there's a lot of talks
about this whether you know it'll get
there or not a lot of people are
concerned uh you're hearing words being
thrown around of a World War III and
that's been trending on Twitter on a few
different days from your perspective of
somebody that's been in this your
father's been in this this has been your
topic of discussion for your entire life
How likely is it that will get there
that a Putin or someone will take the
first initiative of turning into a
nuclear war
so I don't think we're going to get to
uh a world war three where the United
States and Russia are lobbying nuclear
weapons at each other they are both
highly highly motivated not to do
something that could lead to the end of
both countries as functioning societies
what I'm more worried about is the
possibility that Russia might use a few
nuclear weapons in Ukraine uh itself the
United States uh has said that it would
respond in ways that were catastrophic
for Russia uh what I'm hearing is not a
nuclear response but rather a political
economic sanctions but also conventional
military uh responses
in that event but we would have to
expect that Russia would then respond to
that and the situation could get quite
dangerous nonetheless I think it's very
very unlikely we'd end up ending up with
anything remotely resembling what people
think of as World War III got it so
World War III to you would be as if U.S
got involved How likely is it if a Pearl
Harbor type of a situation happens when
Japan attacks us and then a few years
later that happened under FDR and a few
years later under Truman he decides to
Nuke them and it's the only time this
has happened two times in a history of
mankind where we've actually nuked the
place How likely is it that this will be
only between Russia and Ukraine where
Putin to save face and how the world is
pitching him at the end of his career to
say this is not going to be happening in
he nukes Ukraine and then there's a you
know agreement and it's over it versus a
world war three
so I think there are a number of
different ways it could play out uh very
few of which lead to World War III the
reality is uh Russia has thousands of
nuclear weapons uh the United States has
thousands of nuclear weapons each of
them are highly highly motivated not to
lob nuclear weapons at the other uh but
in Ukraine
uh Putin can't afford to lose
politically and he is losing at the
moment and he has threatened that he
would use all weapons at his disposal if
the ukrainians uh attacked areas that he
considers now part of Russia which the
ukrainians are highly motivated to do
now is that a bluff possibly I think
there's only maybe a 10 20 chance that
he would use a few nuclear weapons in
Ukraine he might use them
for coercion uh he might you know use a
few uh on a battlefield and then say
unless you agree to my terms I'm going
to start hitting Cities next so that's
what we have to put up with I think the
United States might get involved in that
circumstance not with nuclear weapons
but using conventional strikes for
example on the units that carried out
the uh nuclear strikes in Ukraine so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]